the uk has led a united western response
to his brutality
we are working with allies around the
world on multiple fronts to ensure the
russian dictator feels the full cost of
his invasion
on the military front we provided
ukraine with their weaponry to inflict
significant losses on the invading
russian forces
on the economic front we've worked with
international partners to [ __ ] the
russian economy
but as history has shown us there are
other powerful ways of isolating rogue
regimes
culture and sport can be equally as
effective as economic sanctions if used
in the right way
and so in the last week i've been
working to mobilize the full might of
the uk soft power against the russian
state
and applying pressure both publicly and
privately across the sectors to use
every lever at their disposal to
entrench putin's position as an
international pariah
culture is the third front in the
ukrainian wall
earlier this week i brought together
governing bodies from across sport
and i made the uk's position clear
russia should be stripped of hosting
international sporting events
and russia teams russian teams should
not be allowed to compete abroad
across sport across the arts and
entertainment we're ostracizing putin on
the global stage
the upcoming champions league final and
formula one grand prix will no longer be
held in russia
likewise russia has been banned by uefa
by fifa by world rugby by the
international tennis federation and
interlanding international olympic
committee
venues across the country have been
cancelled by upcoming performance by the
bolshoi and siberian ballets
disney and warner have pulled their
films from russia
netflix have stopped its projects bbc
studios and itv studios have stopped
trading with russia too
and russia has been banned from taking
part in the eurovision song contest
mr speaker putin is now suffering a
sporting and cultural siberia of its own
making
and it will be causing the russian
leader real pain
ask ukrainian tennis player sergi
stahovsky who gave a very moving
interview on the radio earlier this week
a few weeks ago he was playing at the
australian open
now he's back in ukraine preparing to
fight for his country's survival
he said that putin loves nothing better
than watching russia's sports team's
glory on the world stage
his athletes draped in the russian flag
putin needs the kudos of these global
events
to conceal his illegitimacy and the
hideous acts he is perpetrating in
ukraine
the russian despot is desperately trying
to hide the grim extent of his invasion
from his own people
it's why i strongly support and continue
to encourage the kind of emotional
displays of solidarity we've seen across
sporting events in the last week
including the caribou cup final and the
six nations
lights and symbols cannot stop bullets
and bombs
but when russians see their favorite
footballers wearing shirts emblazoned
with the bright blue and yellow of the
ukrainian flag it helps open their eyes
to the cold reality of putin's actions
likewise
every time an international organization
or figure publicly stands up against
what he is doing in ukraine they chip
away at putin's wall of lies
so i thank and i applaud all those in
this country and internationally that
have done so
and i continue to push for organizations
to exile
putin's russia from their ranks
it's why i've called on unesco to bar
russia from hosting his annual world
heritage conference in june
it's absolutely inconceivable that this
event could go ahead in putin's country
as he fires missiles that innocent
civilians in neighboring ukraine
if it does go ahead the uk will not be
attending
and it's why i urge the international
paralympic committee yesterday to
urgently rethink its decision
to allow
athletes from russia and belarus to
compete
mr speaker this pressure works
the ip's decision was the right ipc's
decision was a wrong call and i welcome
the fact that overnight they have
listened and have reversed that decision
this morning
and i wish our athletes the best of luck
in beijing over the coming days
later today i'll be hosting a summit
with countries from all over the globe
to discuss how we can continue to use
the power of sport to isolate putin at
home and abroad
we have to keep ratcheting up the
pressure
putin must fail
in my department we've also been working
tirelessly to use the power of tech and
the media against the russian dictator
and to shut down and counter his
propaganda and lies
because they are key weapons in putin's
arsenal
and so the department's counter
disinformation unit has been working to
identify and remove russian
disinformation online
alongside the us and others we've also
been working closely with platforms to
take pre-emptive action against putin
and to demonstrate the consequences of
his brutality in real time to the
russian people
apple has paused all sales in russia
google has had added new safeguarding
features to google maps and search
whatsapp is hosting a helpline for
state emergency service that sends
people information and critical news
about their local situation
while big tech has stepped up in a
really positive way
we're also encouraging and supporting
platforms to go even further to tackle
certain challenges
including disinformation service
disruptions and the humanitarian crisis
triggered by the conflict
in this digital age the ukrainian war is
being fought on the ground and online
and so we need to use tech wherever we
can as a force for good
to counter putin's aggression
to expose his weaknesses
and to bolster the people fighting for
their survival in ukraine
mr speaker from the very moment putin
began his invasion i was also very clear
that he must not be allowed to exploit
our open and free media to spread
poisonous propaganda into british homes
russia today rt's own editor-in-chief
called the network an information weapon
of the russian state
and that is why i wrote to ofcom last
week urging them to examine any
potential breaches of the broadcasting
code
ofcom has since opened 27 investigations
into rt and are now reviewing whether to
evoke rt's license entirely
in the meantime those investigations
have been taken over by events
and i was very glad to see yesterday
that the channel is now officially off
air on british televisions after it was
shut down on sky freeview and free sat
in the meantime i've written to meta and
tick tock asking them to do everything
that they can do to prevent access to rt
in the uk as they have done in europe
and i'm glad that youtube has already
answered this call and done so
mr speaker we are on the side of free
media
that was why it was brilliant to see
that the audience for bbc's russian
languages news website has gone up from
3.1 million to 10.7 million in the last
week
and despite his best efforts to censor
reporting in russia putin's own citizens
are turning to factual independent
information in their millions and at
this point
i'd just like to offer my heartfelt
thanks and
admiration to all of those journalists
working for the bbc
the itv and other news outlets who are
risking their lives to bring us unbiased
and accurate news from a live water
mr speaker we will keep ratcheting up
the pressure on putin
and i will use all the levers in my
department to ensure that he is fully
ostracized from the international
community